[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend beginnen wir mit einem
ungewöhnlichen politik ereignis frank
walter steinmeier ist in new york seit
fast 40 jahren ist kein deutsches
staatsoberhaupt mehr dorthin gereist um
vor der jährlichen vollversammlung der
vereinten nationen zu sprechen im engen
korsett des un protokolls wo auch
präsidenten nur 15 minuten zeit bekommen
es war ihm die reise wert kurz vor der
wahl in deutschland
nach diesem unheilvollen sommer der
niederlage in afghanistan und schon
dafür ist sein auftritt der rede wert
johannes hano bericht zwei tage vor der
bundestagswahl kamen nach new york um
der welt zu versichern dass deutschland
auch nach der ära angela merkel seine
internationale verantwortung wahrnehmen
werde da sich die deutsche außenpolitik
aber verändern müsse und er setzte in
seiner rede zu beginn den ton für eine
neue zeit in
meinen augen beginnt außenpolitische
verantwortung der präsident mit einem
ehrlichen
unverstellten blick auf die welt und der
bundespräsident machte gleich klar wie
ernst damit meint anders als der us
präsident am anfang der woche sprach
frank walter steinmeier in
schonungsloser offenheit über das
scheitern in afghanistan
wir haben es in zwei jahrzehnte nicht
vermocht trotz größter anstrengungen
investitionen
eine selbsttragende politische ordnung
in afghanistan zu berichten ich frage
uns was folgt aus dem scheitern er
machte klar dass ein umdenken
stattfinden muss weniger
sendungsbewusstsein sondern mehr
offenheit in der suche nach lösungswegen
wir müssen realistisch sein in der
definition und priorisierung unserer
ziele und interessen
oftmals mal damen und herren können wir
mehr
wenn wir weniger wollen und dann einen
seitenhieb auf die amerikaner die mit
ihrem unabgesprochenen abzug aus
afghanistan und dem heimlich ein
gefährdeten u- boote mit australien viel
porzellan zwischen den verbündeten
zerschlagen hatten wir wissen dass die
usa neue und andere schwerpunkte setzen
und wir wissen so wie die welt sich
ändert müssen nach bündnisse sich
anpassen aber kein kurzfristiger vorteil
ist es wert dass
unsere transatlantische geschlossenheit
risse bekommt darauf sollten wir
miteinander acht geben die welt habe
sich verändert und so müsse sich auch
die deutsche und europäische
außenpolitik verändern mahnte der
bundespräsident
deutsche und europäische außenpolitik
darf sich nicht aufs recht haben und
vorurteilen beschränken sondern
wir müssen unseren instrumenten kassen
eher kasten erweitern
diplomatisch militärisch zivile
humanitäre
nur ein auch militärisch starkes europa
so die botschaft des bundespräsidenten
ist die realitäten annehmen und nicht
beleidigt sei dass sich die welt
verändert könne seine interessen in
zukunft selbstbewusst vertreten
johannes 38 jahre hat kein deutscher
bundespräsident vor der un gesprochen
warum steinmeier und warum jetzt
also die rede hatte einen doppelten
zweck zum einen hat er natürlich ganz
klar auch an die internationale
weltgemeinschaft sich gerichtet und
ihnen versucht klarzumachen es wird
einen friedlichen wechsel in deutschland
geben deutschland wird ein stabiler
partner bleiben und das ist ja nicht
mehr so ganz selbstverständlich auch in
demokratien aber der eigentliche klarer
adressat war das deutsche politische
establishment
er hat ja klar gemacht die
außenpolitischen realitäten haben sich
verändert mit dem scheitern in
afghanistan und der amerikanischen um
orientierung richtung asien deutschland
und europa müssten realistischer werden
man müsse weniger sendungsbewusstsein an
den tag legen weniger wunsch stecken
sondern pragmatischer und mehr
realpolitik betreiben
das war die ganz klare aussage hier und
dazu gehört eben auch mehr verantwortung
zu übernehmen militärisch das war eine
mahnung an das deutsche politische
establishment bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen die nach dem
sonntag folgen werden bloß keine fehler
zu machen denn man muss damit rechnen
dass deutschland als selbst
verantwortung übernehmen muss mit europa
wenn man eine zukunft selbst in die hand
nehmen will
dankeschön johannes am ende des schier
endlosen wahlkampfes ist heute jetzt ein
letzter tag noch einmal soll man
hinhören kundgebungen aller parteien
alle unter der herausforderungen nun
noch mal frisch und interessant zu
klingen was natürlich niemand geschafft
hat beginnen wir mit den parteien die
noch aussicht haben aufs kanzleramt und
in den seriösen umfragen kopf an kopf
liegen so um die mitte 20 prozent stefan
leifert über union und spd
am ende weiß armin laschet gar nicht
wohin mit der ganzen zuneigung die er
von der csu plötzlich erhält es ist das
ende eines abends bei dem die csu noch
einmal alles aufbietet was in bayern
geht
[Applaus]
offizieller wahlkampfschluss auf
münchens nockherberg markus söder hat
seiner partei laschet begeisterung
verordnet und versucht die reihen hinter
dem kandidaten zu schließen mit dem
gemeinsamen feind bild rot grün
es gibt nur eine chance dies zu
verhindern und diese chance besteht in
einer bürgerlichen führung besteht in
einem kanzleramt in dem die union
regiert und deswegen sind wir aus voller
überzeugung mit ganzem herzen dafür dass
armin laschet unser kandidat auch unser
kanzler wird meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren doch es wird knapp lange
nicht mehr war es so ungemütlich vor
einer wahl für die union die warnung vor
einem linksrutsch ist auch lasches
grundmelodie dieses wahlkampf finales
sie fangen wieder an mit ihren alten
sozialistischen köpfen der 80er jahre
bürokratie steuererhöhungen leute
bevormunden ihnen vorschreiben wie sie
zu reden haben nein wir haben
selbstständige bürger die wissen das
besser als diese ideologen die da
herumlaufen
und dann ist da noch angela merkel in
den wahlkampf hat sie sich kaum
eingeschaltet schaute zu wie sich cdu
und csu erst einen offenen dann subtilen
machtkampf liefern ihre mahnung heute
kommt spät nur wenn wir gemeinsam
arbeiten sind wir stark und weil es
nicht egal ist wer regiert haben wir uns
immer wieder zusammengerauft für
deutschland und für das wohl der
menschen in unserem land
vom zusammenraufen können sich hier
gerade ein lied singen ein bisschen
wundert sich die spd über sich selbst
wie geschlossen sie hinter dem mann
steht den sie nicht zum vorsitzenden
haben wollte geht am sonntag um eine
ganz entscheidende frage scholz oder
laschet und ich glaube da findet jeder
die antwort von ganz alleine vielen dank
was für die union eine richtungswahl ist
für die spd in diesem finish eine
personenwahl olaf scholz lässt die
warnungen vor dem linksrutsch an sich
abperlen wer jetzt wie die cdu/csu und
auch die fdp in dieser lage verspricht
dass leute wie ich oder leute die noch
mehr verdienen als ein bundesminister
jetzt mal dringend eine steuersenkung
brauchen dass das 30 milliarden euro im
jahr kosten darf der kann nicht rechnen
der versteht nichts von finanzen aber
der handel auch unsolidarisch und das
ist völlig aus der zeit gefallen seit
wochen führt scholz die umfragen seine
partei profitiert vom kandidaten das
selbstbewusstsein der sozialdemokraten
ist groß kurz vor der wahl
geht wählen wählt demokratischen welt
sozialdemokratisch wir haben ein
sozialdemokratisches jahrzehnt vor uns
und wir haben die wahl holen und so wird
an diesem abend noch einmal gesagt was
schon zigmal gesagt wurde einmal noch
werben einmal noch warnen dann hat
deutschland das wort wer einzieht ins
kanzleramt
dieser wahlsonntag wird das grundgesetz
wieder mal ins gedächtnis zu rufen dort
ist ja geregelt dass die bürger keine
kanzlerin und keinen kanzler willen
sondern ein parlament 67 vielleicht 800
abgeordnete und die entscheiden dann die
k frage nach ihren überzeugungen
interessen und partei loyalitäten und
wenn die umfragen sich völlig daneben
liegen werden dann unweigerlich grüne
und die fdp
schlüsselrollen spielen weil nämlich
weder laschet noch scholz kanzler werden
kann ohne mindestens eine der beiden die
beiden parteien sitzen also an einem
langen hebel solange sie sich nicht
festlegen und da muss man dann am ende
dankbar sein bei der analyse für jede
kleine geste und jeden zwischen ton zum
beispiel heute.de ferber berichtet es
ist voll in düsseldorf bei der
abschlusskundgebung den grünen
vielleicht auch weil im anschluss von
mir direkt die zweites verführer demo
startet das klima treibt sie um sie
wollen wechseln und mehr verantwortung
anders als jetzt robert habeck
wir brauchen wieder politik die bereit
ist die zeit des mandates zu nutzen das
beste rauszuholen aber voll ins risiko
zu gehen um überhaupt jemals wieder
erfolgreich sein zu können neuen
aufbruch wagen das motto der grüne auch
wenn die umfragen keine kanzlerin
baerbock hergeben wollen es bleibe eine
richtungswahl wir können uns keine
halben sachen mehr leisten es braucht
jetzt endlich eine klima bundesregierung
aus voller kraft aus ganzem herzen und
mit voller leidenschaft
eine klima bundesregierung nur mit wem
ein linkes bündnis wünschen sich die
meisten hier aber was wenn das nicht
klappt das ganz wichtig ist den
klimaschutz in der regierung ganz fest
zu verankern dann wird man sehen in
welcher konstellation es am besten
möglich ist demokraten wenn am ende
immer eine koalition ich habe zusammen
finden ich denke aber dass das beste für
das land wäre wenn da
mal was passiert wenn es dort eine
regierung ohne unions betätigung gibt da
werde ich auch in einer koalition mit
den effekten mit der das würdig
verzeichnen aber mit der cdu nicht die
fdp an diesem abend in berlin es ist
auch endspurt hier im landtagswahlkampf
parteichef lindner wirkt ebenfalls für
den wechsel in berlin und dem bund es
brauche dafür auf jeden fall die fdp die
durchsetzungskraft von cdu/csu alleine
ohne eine starke fdp gegenüber den
grünen werden noch geringer als vor vier
jahren um deshalb die freien demokraten
der einzige garant für eine politik der
mitte in diesem land der wunsch hier am
liebsten mit der cdu selbst wenn es
keine offizielle koalitionsaussage gibt
und die zusammenarbeit mit den grünen
irgendwie würde man damit auch
zurechtkommen ich denke man hat zum
beispiel im klimaschutz gleiche ziele
verschiedene wege da muss man dann
gucken ob es möglichkeiten gibt das man
auf dem gemeinsamen weg und ich denke
das hat sich in den letzten vier jahren
etwas geändert hat sich auch vielleicht
die fdp und die grünen habe ich noch ein
bisschen näher kennengelernt auch im
bundestag das macht natürlich sagen kann
jetzt nicht zurückkommen was war damals
sondern man muss eben einfach
entscheiden wie passt es wo gibt es mit
mengen eine schnittmenge ein liberale
und grüne bei dieser wahl beide sind
wohl entscheidend für die
koalitionsbildung so oder so
und dann gebührt zwei weiteren parteien
noch aufmerksamkeit sie sind im jetzigen
bundestag vertreten und werden es
wahrscheinlich auch im nächsten seinen
die afd nach den umfragen mit sicherheit
für die linke ist das bei knapp über der
mindestgrenze von 5% alles andere als
sicher dafür hat sie die linke was die
afd fundamental nicht hat nämlich eine
politische und rechnerische chance in
einer koalition mit spd und grünen teil
einer regierungskoalition zu werden
obwohl die beiden betroffenen das thema
nach kräften vermeiden christiane hütter
berichtet
endspurt für die linke auf dem berliner
alexanderplatz ihr wahlkampf lief
schleppend an erst die linksrutsch
debatte hat der partei auf den letzten
metern die dringend benötigte
aufmerksamkeit verschafft ich denke es
hat den wahlkampf auf jeden fall etwas
politisiert oder sind mehr inhalte in
diesem wahlkampf deutlich geworden also
bezahlbarem wohnraum sichere rente
höhere mindestlöhne klimaschutz also das
wurde jetzt einfach in den letzten
wochen noch deutlich stärker diskutiert
zweistellig wollten sie werden so hat er
es fraktionschefs als ziel ausgegeben
doch daraus wird wohl nichts die umfrage
kurve für die linkspartei seit monaten
liegt sie wie ein brett auch jetzt nur
bei sechs prozent
im besten fall wird die linke braucht
fürs regieren im schlechtesten fall
rutscht sie unter die fünf prozent hürde
lastminute lagerwahlkampf olaf scholz
wird seine ziele höhere besteuerung der
superreichen 12 euro mindestlohn
kindergrundsicherung das alles wird er
nicht durchsetzen eine ampel und
deswegen steht am sonntag auch die frage
linda oder linke rote linien die betonen
sie weiter aber wer genau hinhört heute
hört auch dass die linke sich locker
macht für mögliche sondierungen der
kompromiss kann nur an der länge des
schritts bestehen das heißt alle
schritte müssen in die richtige richtung
gehen sie können nur kürzer sein als wir
uns das gedacht war mit ihnen will
definitiv niemand koalieren letzte
großveranstaltung der afg in berlin auch
sie hatte mühe überhaupt aufzufallen in
diesem wahlkampf mit ihrem dagegen kurs
gegen migration gegen klimapolitik gegen
das impfen ist auch völlig okay wenn man
sich nicht impfen lässt und der staat
hat diese leute in ruhe zu lassen
ich bin da auch nicht gehen als nächstes
kommt die über griffigkeit dass sie
gefragt wenn das er gefragt wird was er
für eine autofahrt und dann ist es einen
diesel und dann seid ihr dran schweine
diese gesinnung fragen müssen aufhören
in den umfragen hängt die afg bei zehn
prozent fest dürfte ihr 2017 ergebnis
nicht wieder erreichen und der
co-parteichef stellt schon vor dem
wahlsonntag die eigene strategie infrage
ich habe da gewisse zweifel ob wir uns
substanziell werden verbessern können
das ist so wenn man den wahlkampf sehr
stark auf die auf die eigene blase
ausrichten das ist sicher nicht so es
war der einzige gemeinsame auftritt von
leuten und den beiden spitzenkandidaten
heute die afg überdeckt nur mühsam den
großen richtungsstreit der im inneren
schwelt nach dem wahlsonntag könnte das
vollends aufbrechen
dieser letzte freitag vor der deutschen
bundestagswahl war für die friday is for
future weltweit nach langer pandemie
pause die erste chance wieder massiv auf
die straßen statt in die schulden zu
gehen allein in deutschland waren wohl
mehr als 100.000 auf den beinen die
bewegung selbst spricht von 600.000
polizeiangaben lagen deutlich darunter
man muss aber keine erbsenzählerei
betreiben um die politische energie des
klima themas zu beweisen die pandemie
liefert der bewegung treibstoff weil die
weltgemeinschaft in der pandemie
bewiesen hat was möglich ist was es ihr
plötzlich wert ist wenn ein problem mal
als existenziell erkannt wurde wie die
pandemie dann spielten hunderte von
milliarden und die interessen der
wirtschaft plötzlich keine entscheidende
rolle mehr und solche radikale
ernsthaftigkeit fordert greta tim berg
heute in berlin auch fürs klima
keins der deutschen wahlprogramme bringt
genügend klimaschutz sagte berg also
wohl auch das grüne programm nicht die
grüne annalena baerbock und alexander
dobrindt csu sind heute am ende des
tages zu gast im journal update nur 15
alle gespräche mit allen parteien diese
woche auf zdf heute nachrichten nun von
gundula gause die eu wirft russland
gezielte cyberangriffe kurz vor der
bundestagswahl vor hacker versuchten
sich zugriff auf computer von
zahlreichen abgeordneten und
regierungsbeamten zu verschaffen ebenso
wie auf daten der presse und der
zivilgesellschaft in der eu hinter den
attacken wird der russische militär
geheimdienst vermutet der eu
außenbeauftragte borel forderte moskau
auf die hacker angriffe sofort zu
beenden andernfalls behalte sich die eu
weitere schritte vor
us präsident biden hat in washington bei
einem treffen mit seinen amtskollegen
aus indien japan und australien eine
gemeinsame agenda für einen freien
indopazifik raum beschrieben diese vier
länder gruppe hatte biden nach seinem
amtsantritt zusammengerufen ziel der usa
und der partner am indischen ozean ist
es dem chinesischen expansionsdrang in
der region demokratische grundwerte
entgegenzusetzen auch chinas
handelspraktiken sind thema des
gesprächs im weißen haus
die britische regierung will sich
verstärkt um lkw-fahrer bemühen nachdem
brax it und die pandemie eine krise im
transportgewerbe ausgelöst haben
zehntausende fahrer sind in die eu
zurückgekehrt jetzt sollen gesetze
geändert werden um die ausbildung
britischer trucker zu erleichtern die
durch den fahrermangel entstandenen
versorgungsengpässe bei lebensmitteln
treffen nun auch die tankstellen die
vielerorts sogar zeitweise schließen
mussten zwar gibt es genügend sprit auf
der insel aber die lieferketten sind
wegen des fahrer mangels gestört der
katalanische separatisten anführer
putschte mann ist nach seiner festnahme
in italien unter auflagen wieder auf
freiem fuß bei einer gerichtsverhandlung
anfang oktober soll entschieden werden
ob er an spanien ausgeliefert wird die
spanische justiz will putschte man den
prozess machen wegen seiner rolle 2017
bei den katalanischen
unabhängigkeitsbestrebungen
seither lebte der frühere
regionalpräsidentin exil um einem
verfahren zu entgehen
nach dänemark und großbritannien beendet
auch norwegen seine corona maßnahmen ab
16 uhr morgen nachmittag fallen
teilnehmer beschränkungen bei
veranstaltungen weg ebenso wie die
abstandsregeln eine landesweite pflicht
zum maske tragen gab es in norwegen
nicht nur lokale regelungen fast 84
prozent aller erwachsenen in norwegen
sind vollständig geimpft in deutschland
meldet das rk ii 9
1727 neuinfektionen binnen eines tages
die sieben tage incidents singt weiter
leicht auf
62,5 seit gestern mussten 515 weitere
infizierte ins krankenhaus die
hospitalisierung rate sank ebenfalls
leicht auf
1,58 in den letzten tagen mehrten
gerüchte aus dem vatikan erwartungen
dass papst franziskus kardinal wiki den
erzbischof von köln aus dem amt
entfernen könnte das hätte das ergebnis
werden können der arbeit von zwei
päpstlichen visitatoren die im juli eine
woche lang in köln ermittlungen führten
zu möglicherweise sagen wir mangelhafter
aufklärung von missbrauchsfällen über
den besuch und dem bericht lag seitdem
ein vatikanischer schleier des
schweigens heute die entscheidung des
papstes burki darf bleiben dagegen gibt
es keine berufungsinstanz aber massive
enttäuschung
und kritik als volk gern berichtet es
ist wohl zumindest vorerst sein letzter
öffentlicher auftritt als erzbischof in
köln er habe fehler gemacht ja sagt
kardinal woelki und er bedauere das und
er berichtet von einem gespräch mit dem
papst der erzähler und bau auf ihn und
habe seinen aufklärungswillen gewürdigt
deshalb bleibe er im amt
habe in dem gespräch mit dem heiligen
vater ihm dann auch schon von einem
länger in mir gereiften gedanken
berichtet nämlich dass ich gerne eine
längere auszeit nehmen würde um die
geschehnisse und die ereignisse der
vergangenen monate für mich
einzuordnen aufzuarbeiten
woelki war vorgeworfen worden die
aufarbeitung von fällen sexuellen gewalt
dem bistum verzögert zu haben weil er
ein gutachten lange zurückgehalten hatte
diesen vorwurf sieht der heilige stuhl
und widerlegt auch habe sich kein
hinweis auf rechtswidriges verhalten
ergeben deshalb keine amtsenthebung aber
fast fünf monate auszeit und köln sorgt
die entscheidung für unverständnis
ich denke mal im amt bleiben dass ich
das richtige zumindest nicht für die
gläubigen wenn man das hört und liest
die sicher sehr unzufrieden mit der
situation hätte ausgetreten werden
müssen nicht selber austreten hätte das
wirklich gesagt bekommen sollen und auch
mit der maßgabe
nicht dass offen lassen dass er wieder
zurückkommt auch der vorsitzende der
bischofskonferenz georg bätzing reagiert
skeptisch einerseits sehe er den willen
das geschehene aufzuarbeiten teilte er
schriftlich mit andererseits lässt es
angesichts der entstandenen lage viele
betroffene ratlos und verletzt zurück
patrick bauer zum beispiel er wurde als
kind von einem pater missbraucht der
papst hätte wolke des amtes entheben
müssen sagt er die entscheidung aus rom
ist wie ein nasser lappen ins gesicht da
hat er mir auch genauso gut in die
kniekehle treten können oder mit dem
wagen umfallen können das überhaupt
keinen unterschied er hat ganz klar
gesagt ihr seid mir egal
patrick bauer hat inzwischen fast
resigniert und wie es nach der auszeit
des kardinals ein bis zum köln weiter
geht ist doch völlig offen man muss
sehen ob beide seiten aufeinander
zugehen also auch der kardinal nach
seiner auszeit sich bewegt wenn das
passiert dann kann vielleicht versöhnung
und erneuerung im erzbistum köln
gelingen wenn das nicht funktioniert
dann wird der papst erneut entscheiden
müssen und dann könnte das heute trotz
der klaren rückenstärkung aus rom für
kardinal woelki auch ein rücktritt auf
raten seien so weit in die zukunft
wollte kardinal woelki heute aber nicht
blicken
die antwort wird es frühestens nächstes
jahr im märz zur fastenzeit geben
nachricht noch mal von gundel
immobilien in deutschland werden immer
teurer käufer von eigentumswohnungen und
häusern mussten im zweiten quartal fast
elf prozent mehr zahlen als ein jahr
zuvor teilte das statistische bundesamt
mit das sei der stärkste anstieg seit
beginn der erhebungen vor über 20 jahren
ein ende des preisanstiegs sei
angesichts der hohen nachfrage vorerst
nicht in sicht
der us-konzern tesla hat kritik am bau
seiner auto und batterie fabrik im
brandenburgischen grünheide
zurückgewiesen im wettbewerb um batterie
zellproduktion in deutschland hat heute
auch die daimler tochter mercedes eine
enorme investition angekündigt sina es
sind wiegand tische vorhaben wer hat die
nase vorn also es tatsächlich ein
brisantes wettrennen um die
batterieproduktion made in germany
einerseits tesla andererseits nun
daimler auch die schwaben setzen auf
deutsche batterieproduktion der konzern
will sich unabhängig machen von
asiatischen batterien bisher kommt der
innere antrieb der elektroautos meist
aus südkorea und china das soll sich
ändern
gemeinsam mit dem französischen stil
anthes konzern zu dem auch opel gehört
und dem ölriesen total werden knapp
sieben milliarden euro in die
batterieproduktion in deutschland und
frankreich investiert daimler zahlt
davon weniger als eine milliarde das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium jung
fördert batterie projekte in deutschland
mit rund 3 milliarden euro 10.000
arbeitsplätze sollen hier entstehen
daimler plant zwar weitere giga factory
es doch kritiker bemängeln sie kommen zu
spät konkurrent volkswagen hat zwei
jahre früher gestartet ja wann das tesla
werk tatsächlich die produktion starten
kann ist fraglich eine drei wochen
dauernde online debatte gegen den bau
des werkes ist heute gestartet tesla
hält die 800 einwände gegen das geplante
werk für unbegründet in wenigen wochen
will tesla mit der produktion loslegen
und lesen loslegen wollen auch die
anleger doch sie brauchen geduld vor
diesem wochenende der dax schließt im
minus mit einem stand von 15.500 32
punkten ja wer regiert deutschland
künftig diese spannende frage er ist
auch die börse nicht kalt aber wie
vielen dank wieder meine
in der fußball bundesliga hat der
sechste spieltag begonnen mit dem
auftritt von bayern münchen bei
aufsteiger greuther fürth die partie
ging gerade eben zu ende gewonnen haben
die bayern es war ein 3 zu 1 sieg gegen
die franken
auf la palma mussten wegen des
vulkanausbruchs weitere 1000 menschen in
sicherheit gebracht werden
regierungschef sanchez will die gesamte
kanarische insel zum katastrophengebiet
erklären und pläne für den wiederaufbau
verabschieden weiterhin tritt lava aus
immer neuen ehrt rissen die zahl der
zerstörten häuser ist auf fast 400
gestiegen die von lava bedeckte fläche
wird laut experten jahrzehntelang weder
bebaut noch landwirtschaftlich genutzt
werden können eine erstaunliche ausnahme
wie durch ein wunder blieb ein haus
inmitten der lava wüste verschont
das wahre setzt von uns an diesem
letzten werktag der woche der wahl
genießen wir alle miteinander einen
hoffentlich sonnigen samstag und dann
wird er sonntag ein richtiger werktag
ganz besonders
gutes wochenende ist morgen
[Musik]
guten abend es wird nochmal ein recht
sommerliches wochenende zwischen dem
hoch hier über dem zentralen mittelmeer
und dem tief über die iberischen
halbinsel kommt nämlich noch mal sehr
warme luft nach mitteleuropa
das tiefe dem atlantik hält noch abstand
von uns und so liegen die temperaturen
morgen in west und mitteleuropa noch mal
bei 15 bis zum teil 25 grad noch wärmer
es ist am mittelmeer mit 20 bis 35 grad
warm bleibt es ja unter wolken allgemein
und das ist hier in der nacht wieder der
fall in norddeutschland im süden ist es
dagegen klar und dort sinken die
temperaturen auf einstellige 9 bis 4
grad der weil es unter den wolken bei 16
bis 10 grad deutlich milder bleibt und
morgen erwarten uns dann
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 18 grad auf
rügen und 27 grad zum beispiel im
breisgau es gibt also häufig noch mal
werte über 20 grad und in einem streifen
zwischen der uckermark und dem emsland
bleibt es morgen bedeckt das ist der
rest einer kleinen wolken schlepper
einer kleinen kaltfront an den christen
sehen sie häufiger die sonne und auch
wir den mittelgebirgen besonders
strahlend sonnig wird es aber in
süddeutschland am sonntag ändert sich
alles denn von südwesten kommen kräftige
schauer und gewitter heran die bis zum
abend auch nordrhein westfalen hessen
thüringen und bayern erreichen die
temperaturen steigen auf 21 bis 26 grad
und von all den bekommen sie im
nordosten also auch rund um berlin
nichts mit da kommen die gewitter erst
am montag hatten guten abend